im schatten des hermannsdenkmals im
westfälischen detmold liegt eine
waldbühne ein beliebter ort für
open-air-veranstaltungen da sind der
region ja auch im sommer häufiger regnet
lässt die kreisverwaltung ein
regenschutz für die zuschauer bauen
400.000 euro hat diese überdimensionale
schirm gekostet aber er funktioniert
nicht das ding liegt jetzt seit vier
jahren nutzlos im lager herum unmöglich
ist doch unmöglich wenn man so was macht
dann muss man es richtig durchdenken man
das nicht richtig durchgehend kommt
natürlich so etwas dabei heraus jetzt
trage ich eigentlich nur die waldbühne
eine wunderschöne einrichtung gut
gemacht dann auch ähnliches aber ich
glaube das war vorher abzusehen dass das
ding wahrscheinlich funktionieren wird
die müssen doch wissen ob es
funktioniert oder ob es nicht
funktioniert damit die besucher der
waldbühne bei regen nicht im nassen auf
den bänken hocken gibt die
kreisverwaltung lippe einen regenschutz
in auftrag das teure stück wird
probeweise ein einziges mal aufgebaut
doch mit der mittelstütze deswegen zells
gibt es ein riesenproblem
sie stört massiv beim sogenannten
mondschein kino denn der filmprojekte
stunde genau hinter der stütze stört das
bild
und dann müssen auch noch bäume an denen
der schirm zusätzlich befestigt werden
sollte wegen pilzbefalls gefällt werden
das ganze funktioniert hinten und vorne
nicht die teure überdachung verschwindet
im lager ich kann da nicht irgendwas
anschaffen oder funktioniert ich habe
mal was anderes sagen das packen wir das
ist totes kapital und wir müssen dafür
bluten das ist eigentlich schade
ich finde das jetzt nicht so gut weil es
sind ja sozusagen unsere steuergelder
die dafür drauf gegangen sind
die überdachung hat der landkreis lippe
aber noch lange nicht abgeschrieben im
kreishaus will man jetzt noch mal geld
in die hand nehmen um das dach endlich
aus dem lager in den ball zu bekommen
schriftlich heißt es wird das dach mit
einer mittelstütze aufgestellt entstehen
voraussichtlich mehrkosten von 250.000
euro soll eine alternative lösung ohne
mittelstütze umgesetzt werden
so entstehen voraussichtlich mehrkosten
rund 400.000 euro das dach umzurüsten
würde also nochmal so viel kosten wie
seine komplette anschaffung ein witz
also dann fühle ich mich doch als bürger
die das doch seinen bezahlen veräppelt
da ärgert man sich schon das ist wieder
eine fehlinvestition vielleicht müssen
die besucher auch im nächsten jahr
wieder vorsichtshalber ihre regenmäntel
einpacken denn ob und wie die vermurkste
überdachung überhaupt noch zu retten ist
kann derzeit verlässlich niemand sagen